20 years from now you will be more
disappointed by the things you didn't do
than by the ones you did do
so throw off the bowlines
sail away from the safe harbor catch the
trade winds in your sails explore dream
discover
the secret of getting ahead is getting
started
with courage you will dare to take risks
have the strength to be compassionate
and the wisdom to be humble
courage is the foundation of integrity
give every day the chance to become the
most beautiful of your life
courage is resistance to fear mastery of
fear not absence of fear
the two most important days in your life
are the day you are born in the day you
find out why
the man who does not read has no
advantage over the man who cannot read
it's not the size of the dog in the
fight it's the size of the fight in the
dog
kindness is the language which the deaf
can hear and the blind can see
if you tell the truth you don't have to
remember anything
the fear of death follows from the fear
of life a man who lives fully is
prepared to die at any time
what is the most rigorous law of our
being
growth
i was seldom able to see an opportunity
until it had ceased to be won
a lie can travel halfway around the
world while the truth is putting on its
shoes
always do what is right it will gratify
half of mankind and astound the other
don't go around saying the world owes
you a living the world owes you nothing
it was here first
it is noble to teach oneself but still
nobler to teach others and less trouble
do the right thing it will gratify some
people and astonish the rest
there is no unhappiness like the misery
of citing land again after a cheerful
careless voyage
travel is fatal to prejudice bigotry and
narrow-mindedness and many of our people
need it sorely on these accounts
broad wholesome charitable views of men
and things cannot be acquired by
vegetating in one little corner of the
earth all one's lifetime
take the universe as a whole and it is a
very clever conception and quite
competently carried out but i don't
think much of this globe as a work of
art
it would have been better to take more
time to it and do it right it seems to
me than to rush it through helter
skelter in six days just for reputation
i have found out there ain't no surer
way to find out whether you like people
or hate them than to travel with them
it liberates the vandal to travel you
never saw a bigoted opinionated stubborn
narrow-minded self-conceited almighty
mean man in your life but he had stuck
in one place since he was born and
thought god made the world in dyspepsia
and bile for his especial comfort and
satisfaction
life is short break the rules
forgive quickly kiss slowly love truly
laugh uncontrollably and never regret
anything that makes you smile
never refuse to do a kindness unless the
act would work great injury to yourself
and never refuse to take a drink under
any circumstances
the funniest things are the forbidden
good friends good books and a sleepy
conscience
this is the ideal
life classic a book which people praise
and don't read
i was gratified to be able to answer
promptly and i did
i said i didn't know
wrinkles should merely indicate where
the smiles have been
when we remember we are all mad the
mysteries disappear and life stands
explained
you